the proclaimed justice of the world
government is one of the biggest
hypocracy
I have ever witnessed in any story
justice is one of the most important and
influential themes in one piece that
shapes the flow of events and works as a
driver for many influential characters
but similar to our world justice in one
piece is an issue of much controversy
and debate so what actually is justice
in the world of one piece and why does
it appear so hypocritical in our
perception in its essence justice means
nothing more than treating others fair
and just even though this statement does
not imply of an action is positive or
negative in a broader sense justice is
often associated with the punishment of
someone who did something wrong the idea
behind this is basically an
eye-for-an-eye mentality someone who
committed a crime should be punished in
a way that in its extent is at least
equal to that crime this of course in
its hardest form means that for example
someone who committed a murder should be
punished by death as well at this point
already you will have your own view on
this matter clearly in mind you might
agree with this way of thinking or you
might see it as very flawed fact is
everyone has their own very distinct
sense of what justice means and how it
should be executed same as in reality
justice in one piece is different for
every individual the former marine
admiral kiesza rule states that justice
changes its shape depending on where you
stand so where in the world you live
what group you belong to how you grew up
and who you are as a person all
influences your view on justice now when
you hear about justice in one piece the
very first thing you will probably
associate with this term are the Marines
justice is their ultimate model that
they use as a vindication for the
actions and even in plays on their
officers coats the initial idea behind
this is pretty straightforward the
Marines are the good ones that protect
the world from the pirates and other
criminals who are yeah the bad guys but
since the heroes of our stories are
pirates we soon discover that the world
is not simply black and white early on
in the story Luffy liberate Zorro from
the hands of Captain Morgan to the
surprise of everyone the Marine
stationed at the base all thanked Luffy
for liberating them as well from the
tyranny of their captain and with that
Oda showed us from pretty early on in
the story that his world is morally
the lines between good and bad are very
fluent not only in the groups like the
Pirates or the Marines but often also in
individuals themselves a great example
for this is Robin who is capable of
immoral and violent behavior and is also
introduced as an antagonist to Luffy and
his crew only after learning her story
and her unexpected joining of the crew
do we start to see her as a person with
a good heart and over time Robin has
become one of the most popular and loved
characters in one piece this concept is
what makes the characters in the story
so incredibly complex and interesting
another story that has built its success
on this way of character designs well is
Game of Thrones
where there is no pure good or evil in
the characters and where justice is also
presented as a concept that does not
have a clear definition now when we look
back at one piece many of the Pirates
actually fit in this black and white
mentality way of thinking since they
truly are nothing more than criminals
but you have to keep in mind that there
are at least as many who turned towards
the pirate life for very different
reasons a bad standard of living revenge
a dream or simply the wish for freedom
are the motivations for many pirates
including the straw hats and along the
road we meet many people who will be
considered nothing more than criminals
in the eye of the world government that
we actually get to know as the good guys
this includes pirates outcasts and the
revolutionaries and they all have their
own sense of justice and in turn see the
world government and the world Nobles as
the real bad and real unjust side now I
stated also inside of the Marines the
sense of justice varies immensely Oda
actually made it a point of giving each
of the original three Admirals a
different philosophy on justice that
each of them follows zack's ookey better
known as a canoe follows the idea of
absolute justice that is shared by many
in the Marines absolute justice takes
the idea of justice to a very harsh
extreme where anyone who falls under the
category of criminal is prosecuted
regardless of what they really did if
you are a pirate you are guilty
regardless of any good you did or to
what degree you actually committed any
crimes and even if you are a regular
citizen that supports or helps a pirate
in any way you are considered guilty as
well in order to bring someone who's
guilty to justice according to a kinder
anything is allowed in the name of
absolute justice since it doesn't allow
any gray zones what this means in
reality can be seen when a kind of
orders the killing of an entire ship of
innocent civilians on ohhara simply
because one of the scholars of the
island could have been hiding in there
the second Admiral is Borsellino also
known as Keyes aru who follows the model
of unclear justice as the name suggests
Kizer his view on justice is not very
clear on the one hand he often refrained
from taking action simply because it
seems inconvenience to him while on the
other hands he's very merciless and
indifferent once he actually takes
action to him justice is more of a duty
that he sees as a burden and that can be
avoided at some times but has to be
complied with at others very different
to that is al key gee al kg follows a
lazy justice while the name might
suggest something similar to killer
whose mindset al kg is actually the only
of the three who actually takes
circumstances and individual situations
into account when passing judgment he
decided to let rob and go from a Hara
and was happy to see her becoming part
of destroyed crew by showing mercy
compassion and respect towards enemies
that have earned it in his eyes
inevitably he eventually clashed with a
canoe due to the incredibly different
views on justice these different ideas
of Justice showed just how in
homogeneous even the Marines are so why
is the concept of justice that the world
government proclaims for themselves so
hypocritical the answer to that lies in
the way that this so-called justice is
executed in the Wimpy's world the
failure to comply with the idea of
justice by the different law-enforcement
factions of the government is a common
theme in the story in the end their
actions are often considered as equally
bad or even worse than those of the
Pirates they actually target trampling
on the rights and needs of civilians in
order to pursue an agenda such actions
by the Marines include everything from
corrupt officers like Morgan to the
killing of civilians on ohhara by Aquino
one of the most gruesome acts committed
by the Marines in the story was the
slaughter of numerous children and women
in the search for Rajas child the
killing of innocents justified by the
danger of a baby of a criminal that
doesn't really sound like any justice to
me another faction executing justice in
the name of the world government are the
cipher pol agencies
RUP Lucci is famously and repeatedly
shown to only embrace justice as a form
of indication for living out his
bloodlust and cruelty
he puts murder and pain before capture
and pushes the boundaries of bringing
people to justice towards cold-blooded
murder
despite the views that all Pirates are
evil the world government also
introduced a system of the Warlord's
these Pirates are pardoned for all their
past crimes and those that the crewmates
committed and are to a certain extent
even allowed to keep committing more the
government is so to speak willing to
overlook certain things in order to gain
more control and maintained a hold on
society's faith in the strength of
justice the law system itself is down to
its core as far from just as it's
possible judges exist in the one-piece
world but as we saw with robin's trial
they are only for show and hold no real
chance for a fair process as a part of
that the prison of impel down is
designed to prevent any captives from
leaving the place alive even those
without a life sentence die in prison
from a systematic torture they're
sentenced to something that the jailers
find great pleasure in doing the whole
place goes against the very idea of a
real prison keeping criminals with a
life sentence away from society and
making those who did not fit to be
reintegrated into society for a second
chance only in one piece the system does
really not allow any second chances but
the final and maybe worst argument for
the hypocrisy of the world government is
the concept of the world Nobles the fact
that this elite group is accepted from
any moral judgment and even practice
active slavery coz in its essence
against the very idea of justice itself
since you cannot simply exclude someone
from this idea the world Nobles are
allowed to murder rape or anything they
please without being part of a kind
whose absolute justice additionally by
owning most of the wealth in the world
they are also the reason many people
resort to the life of a pirate in the
first place so how can it be that
despite all those atrocities committed
by all sides the Marines are perceived
as righteous and good while the Pirates
and revolutionaries are generally seen
as bad and cruel the best answer to this
question might come from one of the last
people he would expect donki hote
doflamingo has the following words
regarding justice pirates are evil the
Marines are righteous
these terms have always changed
throughout the course of history kids
who have never seen piece and kids who
have never seen war have different
values those who stand at the top
determined what's wrong and what's right
this very place is neutral ground and
justice will prevail you say but of
course it will whoever wins this war
becomes justice so in the world of one
piece the world government has been in
power since the void century and
therefore shape the views on who and
what is right for centuries being
nothing else than an undemocratic regime
with the unknown but nonetheless single
ruler and a royal class that is free
from any moral illegal boundaries
justice against the proclaimed enemy is
nothing more than a tool of propaganda
that hides the injustice of the system
since this regime has been in existence
for such a long time this belief of the
government being the ultimate good and
just entity in the world has sunk in
with large parts of the population that
actually carries this system so you
might wonder what can be done about this
and the simple answer to that is that in
essence this is what Luffy's journey is
going to be all about in the end because
even though the revolutionaries are
invading Marysia right now we can assume
that the final role of liberating the
world will be fulfilled by Luffy since
his ultimate goal is to be free so now
incredibly curious about what you guys
think about the concept of justice in
one piece share your thoughts in the
comments below
if you like this video leave me a thumbs
up and please subscribe to my channel to
be notified for any future content of
mine I hope to see you guys around next
time and until then have a great week
[Music]
you